now this is an important video to make sure you're
not consuming too much protein so i want to tell
you the top sign to know that you're consuming
too much protein and the number one symptom is
gastrointestinal malaise now what is this
gastrointestinal malaise well it's a general
discomfort an uneasiness in your digestive
system like you just feel something's not right
number two dysphoria there's some alteration in
how you feel dysphoria is a state of generalized
unhappiness restlessness dissatisfaction or just
frustration you just don't feel very good and
then we get number three lethargy this is lack of
energy sluggishness and just a lack of enthusiasm
and number four weakness so all four of these
symptoms can indicate that you're consuming too
much protein now on a ketogenic diet you should
never go past 30% of all your calories being
protein in fact i recommend keeping your protein
calories roughly about 20% because what's going to
happen is you might start getting increased bun
blood urea nitrogen and so you're going to get a
lot of protein waste and you may see your urine
being a bit foamy and having a very um kind of
a weird odor but here's the thing the skeletal
muscle protein synthesis which is your dietary
protein turning into muscle protein and repair
occurs when you're consuming protein you know
up to about 25 grams per meal but as you start to
go over this number you get less and less protein
synthesis and you're going to get more and more
oxidation where that protein is going to be burned
as fuel because it's going to turn into sugar so
if you were to double that number let's say you're
consuming 50 grams of protein per meal half of
that protein is not going to be used for synthesis
the creation of new muscle or the repair of
muscle it's going to be used as oxidation or fuel
now what's this going to do to your keto plan it's
going to reduce your keto adaptation it's going to
increase your blood sugars it's going to increase
your insulin a little bit not as much as sugar but
it's going to increase it to a modest amount
and it's going to drop your ketone production
so going on a keto plan is not doing high protein
it's doing a moderate amount of protein so if
you're enjoying my content which i hope you are
and you're applying this knowledge to your health
and you have a success i'd really appreciate you
sharing your success story so click the link down
below to my website where you can upload your
success story so you can help inspire others